a great deal of advice on dating focuses
on what we should ideally say to those
were attracted to yet whom we encounter
as we often do without the help of a
formal introduction should we each
answer remark on the weather or ask
directions to a book shop complement
them on their bag or ask them how their
brunch tastes what unites the varied
recommendations is the notion that it's
what we say to another person that will
determine our level of success in the
trials of dating but in truth what we
would perhaps be wiser to focus on and
what will matter far more to our
eventual results is what we are able to
say to ourselves the so called chat up
lines we really need to dwell on or not
those we address to another person they
are the ones we direct at our own
uncertain and under-confident selves the
lines that can most consolingly help us
to believe that approaching another
person can sometimes be a legitimate
safe decent and plausible thing to do
here is some of what we might learn to
tell ourselves in the face of our fears
we know of course how much there is that
is unappealing and wrong with us we are
the Masters of self-hatred we know all
our worst angles every mistake we've
ever made every idiotic thing we've ever
said in certain moods we can't put any
of this out of our minds and so grow
tongue-tied and furtive fleeing any
possibility of new connections it feels
as if we are wretched beings and that no
one we admire could ever begin to care
about us let alone want to exchange a
few pleasantries with us but we are of
course being monstrously harsh on
ourselves we are bringing a cruel and
unwarranted perfectionism to bear on our
characters we are deeply flawed but so
fortunately is everyone else our errors
and ugly sides don't cast us out from
humanity they are would join us to it
and render us all the more hungry for
and deserving of love we don't claim to
be ideal but nor is anyone else we
should perhaps dare to say hello without
panicking at our shadow sides
what we are terrified of is not just a
no but everything that a know ends up
symbolizing in are anxious Minds a
definitively negative verdict on the
whole of our characters a confirmation
that we don't in essence deserve to
exist it isn't a brush-off that's at
stake a rejection from another person
threatens to confirm all our worst
thoughts about ourselves but the truth
is that if a refusal were to come it
would not be a plebiscite on our right
to live they won't be that they loathe
us profoundly or a sickened by our very
existence rather that they're perhaps
already with somebody else or in need of
some time by themselves after a harsh
breakup or have physical tastes that run
quite innocently in a different
direction
none of it needs to be taken as a
profoundly personal rebuke we should not
let our tendencies to self-hatred blend
in with the inevitable accidents and
mismatches of any journey through the
dating world
the desirable ones have a habit of
seeming very self-contained and complete
they don't usually look as if they would
be interested in meeting anyone new or
as if they could have space in their
lives for someone like us they seem
entirely content reading their book on a
promenade or chatting to their friends
by the check-in desk but there is often
far more space in others hearts than the
surface may suggest we know from our own
experience how much despite an often
busy and competent life we maintain an
appetite for novelty for new kinds of
interaction and sincerity for fresh
sources of kindness and interest we know
how open we might at points be to an
approach from a self-aware and
well-meaning stranger this isn't because
there's anything deficient in us but
because it's the human norm to be
somewhat dissatisfied with parts of
one's existence and to be occasionally
curious about how things might go with
another person it isn't impossible that
someone we like the look of could at the
very same time as us quietly Harbor a
hungry heart
it seems terrifying to try of course but
in the broader scheme of our lives the
risk we are taking by saying hello does
not deserve that terror
we sometimes anxiously afford it we can
survive and know we will soon enough be
stone-cold dead and should use the idea
of our own impending doom to make us
less scared of the many petty challenges
that stand in the way of our plans for
happiness before it's all too late we
should panic ourselves about one big
thing so as to loosen our hold on our
day-to-day inhibitions the thing we must
really be afraid of is not to hear that
they already have a partner but that we
will reach the grave without having
dared to cross a room to say hello
we are terrified of coming across as
foolish but rather than harboring this
fear in a secret part of our fearful
selves we should make ourselves entirely
at peace with our dread and gain
confidence from an open-hearted
acceptance of our own and everyone
else's clumsy ridiculousness of course
we are idiots if we stumbled and set a
silly thing it shouldn't ever been used
to us just confirmation of an already
established and quite Unchained full
truth about everyone the doing stupid
things is a basic feature of being human
though we can't possibly guess at the
exact details the person in front of us
must also have done a great many
ridiculous and strange things in their
own lives being a bit of an idiot should
never disqualify anyone from the
possibility of love
they of course look sublime which may
feel like an argument for never daring
to speak to them we readily imagine that
they could only love someone as
perfectly formed as they are but the
laws of biology and psychology can work
hugely in our favor in the background we
tend to fall in love with people who
remind us of the parent of the gender
were attracted to and many beautiful
people had mercifully ugly parents they
may themselves look stunning but their
personal histories can mean that they
will be inclined to look very
benevolently on our own physical
shortcomings which may touchingly remind
them of their deeply beloved but bald
and short father or kind-hearted yet
short-sighted and plain looking mother
we imagine naturally that they will
already have countless offers there
wonderfulness immediately suggests as
much and out of modesty we walk away the
irony is that everyone will tend to
think the very same thing and therefore
ironically they may be far more alone
and neglected than more average
candidates
none of these aligns we direct at the
other person they are all things we can
afford to say to ourselves as we try to
do that most implausible and needlessly
scary of things introduce ourselves to
an as-yet unknown human that we might
one day share our lives with
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book calmly guides us with
calm and charm through the key issues of
relationships to ensure that success in
love need not be a matter of good luck
for more click the link now